shaloo luna da his house lies in ruins
the pastor once lived here with his
family but that was before Boko Haram
came and attacked his hometown of movie
nadodi was barely able to get his family
to safety in the last minute what I've
been laboring for for many many years I
lost them within just a fraction at time
so I feel it very bad all the church
documents and the church vehicles are
the property we have all burnt down
since then the church next door has
reopened the churchgoers have yet to
return members of the Christian
community have become more cautious we
have over one hundred and thirty seven
churches that have been born in this
area so we are looking at it this way
who did it whose children I a day it is
no Chris and I did it so we are
skeptical about the religion the Emir of
movie is the city's highest ranking
Muslim authority he also had to flee
from Boko Haram because the terrorist
group also kills moderate Muslims since
the Army's liberation of the city he no
longer sees any conflicts will come to
one house you will find that the junior
brother is a Muslim decina brothers
ecclesia with these people fight so
movie is unique about pub of religion
program we have no we have no problem
but chawal una da he seen here in this
temporarily rebuilt church sees things
differently
it will take a long time for them to
forget about this issue because some of
the things that our children have seen
their father have been slaughtered even
when their presence but gradually we
believe we tend to forget it when a sep
one another once more the pastor is
preached forgiveness to his congregation
more frequently in recent months than
before and in spite of all the suffering
he hasn't lost hope for the future